Reggie Miller on loan from Turner Sports
he'll be working Thursday night on TNT
with Kevin Harlan and Kristen Ledlow
they have the Celtics in the 76ers and
the offer still stands - the 76ers for
Reggie to come in and help Ben Simmons
learn how to shoot a three-pointer and I
think his head coach finally came out
and said he kind of failed Ben Simmons
on this that they haven't developed that
three what do you do with him now look I
think you continue to push the envelope
and you've got to tell him that you look
at Yanis on to the kupo and his
three-point numbers this year last year
I think he had a career-high 52 and he's
in the 60s this year and growing teams
are daring the honest to shoot and he's
taking them up on that and they've doing
the same thing to Ben Simmons and he has
to trust in that you saw the reaction
when he made that one this year it was
like he broke Twitter and the Internet
he's got to trust in whoever is teaching
him these three-point shooters and Ray
Allen myself Craig Hodges Dale Ellis
someone has to get with this young man
and number one work on his confidence I
just think his confidence from that
three-point line is a little bit
shattered and someone has to build that
up for him because they'd be someone
build it up for you honest
and right now teams are daring them and
he's making them pay but also you have
marquel Foltz who had a big night last
night it looks like he's you know he's
starting to show that you know he's a
first-round draft pick talent and he's
only 21 but it feels like he's sort of
emerging here quietly in Orlando yes but
I think a chain is the changes scenery
really helped marquel being in Orlando I
think when he when marquel was selected
overall number one everyone kind of
scratched her head you know that he had
that one pretty good year at Washington
but no one had ever heard of marquel
Falls right they didn't make the
tournament he put up gaudy numbers at
Washington in the pac-12 but the pac-12
is not you know a powerhouse
in terms of basketball like it used to
be so there was expectations when he
came to Philly and we know how the
Philly faithful fans are they want you
to perform right away he didn't and then
there was mystery injuries and I think
it might have been the quickest I've
ever seen a number one pick be traded
and then you're right the the change of
scenery have helped the belief the
confidence which we're talking about
with Ben Simmons I think that coaching
staff believing in him and he's starting
to find his way yeah it's good and you
talk about confidence and you were as
confident as anybody and that does play
such a role it's when you miss your
first three or four and then that ball
comes back to you when you have that
unwavering confidence then you'll take
that next shot you see a lot of these
younger players where the like I just
missed three in a row I'm gonna pass it
I mean Lonzo ball was famous for doing
this and and his jumpers improved a lot
but how can you instill confidence in
somebody you know when they're shooting
it's funny theater and not only
confidence in yourself but you know when
that ball comes to you after you've
missed you know three or four shots you
know who else is watching that your
teammates right yeah so when they see
you get the ball on that fourth shot and
you don't shoot and you're supposed to
be the best player and you're getting
all the hype in the marketing for this
team they recognize that and they start
looking at you differently so you know
take that shot Baker miss your teammates
will respect that more as opposed to you
passing that shot talking to Reggie
Miller he's got 76ers Celtics coming up
Thursday night on TNT Rick Carlisle the
Mavs head coach said that Luca dhansak
is getting beat up defenses are being
physical with him does he have a beef
here welcome to being an MVP candidate
damn near a triple-double 30 and
ten and nine or something like that yeah
welcome to being an MVP candidate thank
you welcome to the island of Yanis and
LeBron and James Harden you know that
it's a badge of honor and he's supposed
to say that to protect his player
because he's putting it in the minds of
the officials but he's supposed to say
that you know the James Harden is
getting beat up every single time that
that comes with the territory of being
oh here you go
I'm gonna say it one of the top five you
one of the top five players you're going
to get beat up when you averaged 30
points a game so you got Luka in your
top five now took a while but you're
gonna let him in Yanis Luka LeBron har
game Anthony are we on for yeah Anthony
Davis that's our five that is our five
Steph Curry's out but but let's say he's
healthy
his Stefon your top fine he would be on
the fringe looking out I would have
Kawhi in there but quite as and play
back to back I can't put someone in
there who's gonna play 60 to 62 games a
year but Kawhi would certainly be in
there if he played 70 to 75 games what
happened the other night when Memphis
blows out the Clippers in Los Angeles
and the fans rap booing the Clippers the
thing I really believe that the Clippers
and it's still early
all right this year I get it but I think
they're really starting to believe and
read their own headlines
I've said it they're the best team in LA
that they should represent LA is going
to be them in the Lakers in the
conference finals and they've got you
know the two the two to way the best
two-way players and Paul George and
Kawhi you listen to montrezl harrell
come out and say we need to stop
thinking that we're the best team
they're reading their own headlines
that's the problem
but you
got blown out at home by Memphis Memphis
look no come on I not blown out I can
feel lost but blown out I get it oh my
god
it can't happen but it does happen in
our game if I said let's redraft today
Zion or John Moran I will still take ok
he's going to put people in the seats
true and if he ever gets right which the
New Orleans pelicans are saying close I
wouldn't play in this year read the same
page
people on Twitter disagree with you and
I hi they want to see him back i people
keep hitting me saying you're wrong
he's coming back I think you said he was
done for the season I think it's a
mistake looking at him dunk
during these warmups I pray I just think
he's too heavy Ridge is the third
heaviest player in the NBA I believe I
just don't think it I don't think it's
practical I'm wrong I just I'm looking
out for the kid but I understand what
maybe David Griffin and look they see
him on a everyday basis you and I don't
right so they obviously know more than
we do i I want to err on the side of
caution I would sit him out this year I
would put him on a strict diet he needs
to lose about 30 to 40 pounds oh my god
that's a lot reg I think that 20 at the
most he could probably lose but he's 290
I think taco fallen he weighs 290 pounds
maybe 280 he said I think he's the third
heaviest player in the NBA at six young
men at that talent at those Springs
needs to be playing their 250 I'm right
so he needed to lose 30 or 40 pounds
no but that's unwise he needs to play it
at 250 he would be unstoppable he's
going to be good and unstoppable on
certain games at 280 290 when Charles
lost the weight that MVP and thereafter
Dendi weigh a hundred pounds more than
you when you were rookie I weighed what
yes 180 oh my god you're the same height
I look again you might be no they know I
am taller because when we just did the
game and I saw him in the back I gave
him kappa told me he worked it hard I
was looking down I was looking down okay
but I could not well I went in for the
bro-hug but my arms couldn't cut my
fingers but I couldn't connect
you didn't say you didn't whisper in his
ear salad salad bar he's a good kid
dying yes no he's a good kid and he has
an infectious smile which I love there's
innocence to him oh I'd love to play on
the same team as him I he's she's gonna
be great yes he has all the qualities of
what a superstar is all about you're
right he's selfless he understands he
will understand the game I think he will
be well coached by Alvin Gentry he is
surrounded by good talent in Drew
holiday and favors JJ reddick great
veterans I just think how you say 20
I'll go 25 30 25 30 pounds and he will
be unstoppable Kevin Love I know he
wants to I thought he was gonna get
traded before the year started I I think
he's doing his best to try to get traded
oh I've never heard that one before it's
true I've never heard that one before
but he's watching Collin Sexton what is
he a second-year pro dribbling for 15
seconds and not going anywhere
and finally Kevin Love comes up and just
says just give me the damn ball like
move the ball and these younger players
come in because you know he was the one
man show at Alabama so he's like I I get
to dribble all by one Kevin Love is
going I get me out of here like I let me
go to a team that like could you see him
going to the Lakers then and they would
definitely be the odds-on favorite but
right now they're there the favors come
out of the West and win it all but why
are they trying to trade Kyle Kuzma I
think they're trying to trade college
Kuzma and probably his damn trainer come
on man that was ridiculous okay why add
yeah explain the story I'm going to come
to college defense on one thing I don't
think he was like retweeting what his
trainer had said I think he was
retreating something else that was
written on Twitter that's the only
difference I don't think he was you know
saying yes to his trainer but his
trainer can't say that okay but explain
this story so Kyle kuzmin's trainer
did he retreat them retweet or like no
no Kyle Kyle kuzmin's trainer says
basically that Kauai is a better player
than the Brawn works harder and you guys
are missing the point immediately he
tweeted that out I would say you know
immediately after Kyle said you hear no
arguments from me and people assumed
that he was talking about that tweet and
if you're LeBron James you're looking at
this do because everyone has their own
personal trainers and everyone's
personal trainers are around the
facility so you see this guy all the
time
you can't have this dude at the Lakers
practice facility and you're you're
talking behind my back but I got to see
you I don't think he'll be traded
because of that but you can't talk about
the best player like that but do you
think it's just a coincidence that all
these young players who were there when
LeBron got there are no
longer there except for Kuzma and he's
on on his way out - why do you think
he's still there because of the king
exactly there's no coincidence
LeBron hand-picked that roster yeah
where were no fools Rob palinka could
talk about all he wants that you could
say what do you want the broad
hand-picked @pn picked the coach yeah
come on
would you rather have Brandon dummies
here would you rather have Ingram or
Kuzma hmm see Ingram is coming to his
own in New Orleans I like but he's not a
big market kind of guy though he's from
the south
he's back in the south and he's bawling
wait you think that LA was that mom
who's too big
yes yes really yes I do some players are
built for that some others aren't
we'll see you were a big market talent
playing in a smaller market exactly I
grew nothing I wasn't faded every summer
we were playing with magic and the
Lakers and you know Mike will come
through rural area so I saw everything
I was from a big market and went to a
smaller market I wasn't from Indiana
coming to LA you know I probably my eyes
would have been huge I'll leave you with
this I've given my thoughts on David
Stern the the passing of the the
Commissioner I don't know if you ever
had any you know one-on-one moments
interesting story that you might have
with the Commissioner but if you do I'll
give you the stage too many a 101
especially during those contentious
Pacers versus Knicks series because look
being in a small market which you and I
just mentioned I always thought we were
getting the short end of the stick I
thought we were getting the raw end you
know I thought it was favoritism and I
would publicly kind of say these things
and one time I you know I'm driving down
to practice is my phone's ringing and I
pick it up from an unknown number and
it's like please hold for the
commissioner
[Laughter]
what did I do
you know David Stern gets on the phone
Reggie I'm like yes sir he's like we
here in New York and in the home office
here yes who's winning ball games so I
suggest to you you just go out there and
play back long play hard and let the
chips fall where they may my friend
loved your game but keep it quiet
on a conspiracy theory I'm like yes sir
mr. stern the best leader it probably at
all of stores all a sport yeah I'm not
kidding you because you and I are old
enough to remember when we'd get up at
what 11 or 12 and watch tape delay and
he came in an 84 and changed everything
again now he was the king of marketing
individuals and it helped to have Larry
and magic at the time of that great
rivalry between the Lakers and the
Celtics brewing so fabulous fabulous
leader and fan of the game hope the
family had great holidays and glad to
have you back glad to be back and have
fun with the 76ers and Celtics and if
you get a chance to go out there and
help Ben Simmons that's what he should
ask for he should ask for that for
Christmas that gonna come up to me and
I'm gonna look at him like how we were
supposed to be working out so I'll let
you know that interaction what happened
all right
Happy New Year thank you buddy happy New
Year to my band that's bigger and better
and let's do this thank you brother
that's a Reggie Aloysius Miller the Hall
of Famer four more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]